lo que espero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar la relación entre los precios
del petróleo y la gasolina y tú puedes
notar una fuerte correlación entre las
tendencias en este gráfico de aquí es el
precio del petróleo en un específico
lugar en el planeta esto depende en
donde tu estés el precio está dado en
dólares americanos por barril fíjate que
temprano por ahí del 2008 el precio
estaba alrededor de 100 dólares y
después sufrió hasta 140 dólares y bajó
bruscamente y desde entonces ha estado
oscilando para arriba hasta ahora que
está cercano a 100 dólares por barril
aquí es donde nosotros podemos ver los
precios del petróleo por barril los
costos dependen de la cantidad del
petróleo que haya de en que el lugar
geográficamente específico se encuentran
en los costos de transportación y en los
impuestos que se paguen por la
producción de este los impuestos muchas
veces es lo más importante
puedes ver que tienen hacia arriba
cuando los precios del petróleo suben y
luego descienden y esto es el precio
normal por galón esta gráfica muestra
los precios correctos en nueva york' y
los precios no se mueven completamente
proporcional si hay algo que tú puedes
ver es que el precio del petróleo por
barril normal
es mucho más volátil que el precio de la
gasolina sin embargo la tendencia
general es la misma cuando los precios
del petróleo se mueven para arriba los
precios de la gasolina tienden a subir
pero no siempre en el mismo porcentaje
pero hay definitivamente una relación
ahora antes de intentar averiguar cuánto
vas a pagar es decir en la gasolinera
cuánto de este precio viene del petróleo
cuánto de este precio va a venir de la
refinación y cuánto de este precio va a
venir del transporte esto es justo lo
que me quiero preguntar y responder me
en este vídeo pero antes mira estas
fotos seguro que probablemente estás
familiarizado con estas imágenes se
trata de las plataformas petroleras pero
hay dos tipos muy diferentes esta
primera se trata de una plataforma
petrolífera costa fuera y ésta se trata
de una plataforma terrestre petrolera
pero ambos están haciendo la misma cosa
fundamental están perforando dentro del
suelo hasta que ellos lleguen donde hay
petróleo y entonces extraer el petróleo
hacia afuera y transportarán el petróleo
el mercado pero antes van a tener que
pasar por una refinería aquí en el mar
es realmente rápido como lo extraen
y eso es realmente una ingeniería que
hay que admirar podría estar aquí en el
océano y literalmente van a ir hasta el
fondo del océano van al mar y después al
suelo y luego perforan desde allí para
llegar realmente a los depósitos de
aceite por lo que es realmente una
maravilla de la ingeniería y tienes que
tener mucho cuidado puede ser muy
peligroso trabajar en una plataforma
petrolífera porque si hay un accidente
puede ser una pesadilla ambiental ahora
una vez que tú tengas el petróleo tienes
que conseguir una refinería para que el
petróleo pueda ser dividido en sus
partes útiles y la forma que normalmente
se transporta a una refinería es a
través de una tubería o un barco
petrolero este de mi derecha aquí es un
oleoducto de alaska que toma el petróleo
desde la parte de norte de alaska lo
llevan hasta la parte sur para que ahí
puedan ser colocados en los tanques
petroleros y después lo puedan
transportar a cualquier refinería o
bueno ir a un barco petrolero para que
se pueda transportar e incluso ir más
lejos y luego desde allí a una refinería
bueno ahora vamos a empezar a pensar en
cómo construimos el precio del petróleo
inclusive antes de pensar en qué es lo
que hace
así que vamos a decir que el precio
actual del petróleo y bueno yo he creado
algunos números para que funcione
bastante bien esta explicación así que
vamos a decir que el precio del petróleo
por barril es de 90 dólares
un barril equivale en unidades a 42
galones eso es muy importante
es decir si digo que tengo un barril de
agua realmente estoy diciendo que tengo
42 galones de agua y ahora todos los 42
galones de petróleo crudo no se van a
convertir en 42 galones de gasolina que
más quisiéramos de los 42 galones de
petróleo crudo más o menos se pueden
obtener unos 20 ó 19 galones de gasolina
entonces para hacer los números más
fáciles voy a decir que voy a obtener 20
galones de gasolina y entonces los otros
22 galones serán de otras cosas pero de
estos 22 galones no todo será de
residuos algunas de ellas serán
subproductos otras partes de estos
galones serán usados para alimentar el
proceso de refinamiento etcétera mejor
pondré el resto en otras cosas déjenme
borrarlo y entonces voy a escribir mejor
todo esto como otras cosas pero bueno
vamos a regresar al problema original
entonces estamos diciendo que la
refinería está pagando 90 dólares por
barril y este precio incluye lo que los
productores de petróleo están recibiendo
y también va a incluir el transporte de
la refinería
y otras cosas más y ahora vamos a
fijarnos cuánto gana la refinería no no
mejor digamos incluso que no incluye el
transporte es decir digamos que hay
gente dispuesta a comprar directamente
el pozo en la refinería y también vamos
a decir que están dispuestos a comprar
la gasolina no sé a 3.25 pesos por galón
a esto lo va a vender la refinería vamos
a escribirlo entonces la refinería va a
obtener 3.25 dólares por galón de
gasolina 3.25 dólares por galón ok
entonces vamos a hacer las cuentas qué
es lo que tenemos que cada galón de
gasolina vale 3.25 dólares y tenemos 20
galones de gasolina en total que vamos a
producir por un barril que nos costó 90
dólares por lo tanto vamos a hacer las
cuentas cuánto vamos a obtener de la
gasolina son 20 galones que vamos a
multiplicar por 3 puntos 25 por cada
galón voy a obtener 65 dólares entonces
voy a obtener 65 dólares de la gasolina
de donde voy a obtener lo demás y
entonces vamos a decir por el bien de
explicación
que ellos consiguen este dinero y por lo
tanto van a obtener 35 pesos las otras
cosas es decir de estas otras cosas hay
cosas que son muy útiles por ejemplo se
obtiene aceite de motor o podría ser
combustible de aviones o podría ser gas
natural o cualquier otro tipo de
combustible y de hecho obviamente el
combustible que permita funcionar a la
refinería y la verdad no suena nada mal
para la refinería porque entonces la
refinería va a sacar su propio
combustible de ahí mismo del crudo que
obtuvo al comprar el barril de petróleo
esta es una buena manera de pensar en
ello y así que vamos mejor a graficar lo
entonces el precio es de 3.25 pesos por
galón este es el precio en el cual va a
salir de la refinería por lo tanto vamos
a decir que esto es un dólar estos son
dos dólares estos son tres dólares y
ellos estarán recibiendo 3.25 dólares y
esto está justo aquí eso es lo que la
refinería está recibiendo por la venta
de un galón ojo no todas sus ganancias
provienen de la gasolina sin embargo por
ahora vamos a pensar que la refinería
después de la refinación
en todo este barril de petróleo crudo y
entonces ellos pagaron 90 dólares y de
él van a recibir 65 dólares de la
gasolina y por lo tanto ellos tienen que
obtener mínimo otros 35 dólares de otras
cosas que hicieron es decir de las otras
cosas que van a obtener y para que todo
esto sume una combinación de 100 dólares
fueron capaces de comprar crudo en 90
dólares hacer lo que tenían que hacer y
entonces van a ser capaces de vender por
100 dólares
así que observemos bien al menos en esta
situación el 90% de este dinero era para
obtener todo esto por lo tanto su costo
se va a descomponer entre otras cosas y
la gasolina por lo que no es muy fácil
de descomponer este precio pero se puede
decir en este ejemplo que una buena
parte de este era el costo de la
gasolina el coste de la gasolina me da
unas ciertas ganancias y una gran parte
del costo de la inversión fue el costo
del crudo y entonces seguramente te
estás preguntando cuánto gana la
refinería es decir cuánto es la
diferencia entre lo que pagan por el
crudo que lo que obtienen por la
gasolina
que van a obtener a este margen se le
llama a menudo la propagación de la
grieta o el margen de la grieta o el
crack spirit para entender todo sobre lo
que la refinería está haciendo es que
está rompiendo el petróleo crudo en
diversos componentes es realmente una
forma muy sencilla y eso para no decir
un proceso simple pues no quiero que se
confunda con que una refinería sea una
cosa sencilla obviamente no es así pero
la idea para el proceso realmente
bastante sencilla se toma el petróleo
crudo y luego se calienta a través de
una caldera justo aquí el crudo va a
estar muy caliente por cierto la caldera
está alimentada a menudo por algunas de
las salidas de este mismo petroleum y
luego entra a una columna de destilación
por eso ves a todas estas torres aquí en
una refinería de petróleo estos son las
columnas de destilación y entonces en
cada columna de destilación las
diferentes partes del petróleo tienen
diferentes temperaturas de ebullición
así que las muy largas tienen cadenas de
carbonos de petróleo y lo mantienen
hirviendo a muy altas temperaturas tan
caliente que va a permanecer en su forma
líquida en la parte de abajo
y luego una de las cadenas levemente
pequeñas se van a hervir y evaporar un
poco pero entonces cuando ascienden por
la salida se van a enfriar y esto va a
ser que se condense justo ahí y esto
hace que puede ser llevado en unos tubos
y entonces las cosas tienen cadenas
ligeramente más cortas que serán un poco
más altas antes de enfriarse a
temperaturas aún más bajas para después
volver a un estado líquido y así pueden
ser recogidos aquí todo el camino hasta
llegar a las cadenas más cortas como el
gas natural que sería recogidos en la
cima es decir la gasolina que puedes en
tu coche puede recogerse justo aquí
adentro entonces esencialmente tú estás
descomponiendo el petróleo en sus
diferentes partes en cuanto a algunas de
sus diferentes partes esto puede ser
aceite de motor lo que usted es para
lubricar ojón o combustible tu motor es
posible que tenga algún combustible de
avión por aquí entonces tiene una
tonelada entera de diferentes
combustibles y eso podría ser queroseno
y todo tipo de cosas que tú eres capaz
de sacar de este crudo de todos modos
volvamos a la gasolina así que la
refinería tiene un precio de 3.25
dólares y ahora tenemos que transportar
esta casa
así que vamos a destinar 10 centavos
para el transporte aquí teníamos 3.25
dólares por aquí y más o menos vamos a
agregarle así que ahora vamos a tener 10
centavos para el transporte y voy a
escribir solamente el transporte para
abreviar y luego va a la gasolinera y
como mencioné es fuertemente cargada de
impuestos y depende de la jurisdicción
del país o incluso de estados en el que
te encuentres pero por simplicidad vamos
a decir que se tiene que pagar un
impuesto de 50 centavos por galón lo
cual no es diferente al impuesto de
muchos estados así que ahora estamos en
50 centavos de impuestos por galón para
redondear este es el impuesto para el
gobierno federal y estatal así que vamos
a sumar tendríamos 3.25 dólares que es
lo que la refinería cobran después
obtienen 10 centavos para el transporte
es decir serían 3.35 dólares más 50
centavos del impuesto lo cual nos lleva
hasta 3.85 dólares y entonces ahora que
estamos en la gasolinera esencialmente
costará 3.85 dólares para el combustible
pero la gasolinera tiene que hacer algo
de dinero para pagar sus costos por lo
tanto la gasolinera te va a venderse
combustible en en cuatro dólares por
galón lo que podríamos decir es hey hizo
15 centavos la gasolinera pero una gran
cantidad de estos 15 centavos va
realmente a los procesadores de tarjetas
de crédito porque la mayoría de la gente
paga con sus tarjetas de crédito por lo
que la mayoría de las gasolineras cómo
están inclusive muchas veces te dan un
descuento para pagar en efectivo debido
a que estos 15 centavos en general
alrededor de 5 centavos de estos 15
centavos se van a ir a pagos de la
tarjeta de crédito por lo que el
distribuidor quedará con unos 10
centavos en un margen de ganancia eso es
muy importante antes de que vayas a la
gasolinera y les reclamen no es tanto lo
que se van a quedar ellos con ganancia
porque de estos 15 centavos cinco
centavos se van a ir al pago de las
tarjetas de crédito y disfrutamos para
ellos en fin ojalá que todo este vídeo
te dé un sentido de como el petróleo
crudo se convierta en gasolina y cuando
tú pagas en la estación que es la
composición de diferentes factores
cuánto de ese dinero va a los diferentes
factores de este proceso
espero te haya gustado este vídeo y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo